what do you get when you combine Tim
Curry Kiefer Sutherland Charlie Sheen
Chris O'Donnell Oliver Platt and that
guy with the cool voice whose name you
can never remember in one movie a film a
lot of people barely remember but you
know what that's kind of a shame because
I think this is actually a pretty
legitimately fun action film it has
sword fights it has romance it has
conspiracies it has a villain and it's
all in that over-the-top 90s cheese that
we've all grown to love but nostalgia is
one thing is it actually good well let's
take a look at the story Chris O'Donnell
is d'Artagnan and he's looking to join
the Musketeers a group of people they're
hired to protect the king but the
Musketeers have been disbanded by the
order of the cardinal played by Tim
Curry why so he can have the newly
crowned King assassinated so that he may
take the throne there's only three
musketeers who didn't listen to the
rules and now they're banned as outlaws
so d'Artagnan decides to join them so
that well let's be honest they can form
their own boyband
yeah I mean look at now you got the
heartfelt one the funny one the serious
one and the emo all the girls can't help
but love because oh I just want to hug
him and I guess in some ways you can
attribute that to the film's biggest
problem that yeah it is pretty cliche
and on top of that there's a lot of
characters and so they try to fit a lot
of stories with well a lot of the
traditional cliches in there but in my
opinion there's such fun cliches and
they lead to a really fun movie are you
just waiting for that moment when Chris
O'Donnell is talking about love and
inevitably you know Keifer Sutherlands
just gonna say love ha let me tell you
the story about in love don't you just
love it when oliver platt is trying to
create a quote that could sound
somewhere to god I love being a turtle
gum and five words Tim Curry as the
villain oh my god I'm surprised there's
any scenery left behind him he's chewed
so much he does all the typical
over-the-top Tim Curry stuff we expect
him Curry to do he smiles he looks slimy
he stretches out his vowels
he screams he yells he raises his
eyebrows oh my god it's Tim Curry as the
villain
and that should give you an idea what
kind of moving this is aside from that
the actions not bad either
as well as the common I think possibly
the major problem the film falls into is
well we've kind of seen this stuff
before and we've kind of seen this
formula before the only thing that
really sets it apart again is sort of
the cheese factor and it's passion but I
don't think that's a bad thing on top of
that like I said there are a lot of
characters and to the film's credit they
tried to give every single character a
backstory or a love interest and good
for them they're not passing over
anybody but at the same time it's a lot
to juggle and you kind of forget which
tragic love story were in or who loved
who and I mean it's not terribly
confusing but it's still a lot maybe
there's a part of me that wants to like
it more because I really felt like for
the time they were giving exactly what
audiences want to see this is the kind
of action film people liked watching it
didn't take any big risks and yeah it
was safe and marketable does it make it
a great action film no but at the same
time I think the stunts it does have and
the comedy and B attention to the
characters they'll still make it a
decent flick in that yeah there's a lot
to make fun of but there's also a lot to
have fun with if you're looking for an
action film to pass the test of time and
have a lot of ability to it this one
probably isn't it but if you're looking
for something that's just kind of fun
kind of cheesy has some good action some
good character just a fun little
adventure as opposed to a big grand epic
then I think this is we're checking out
yeah a lot of is standard and we've seen
it before but it's just the right amount
of over-the-top never to the point where
it's insultingly bad but just the right
amount where you're kind of giggling but
having fun with it too it's seriously
overlooked and I think deserves a lot
more attention it's all for fun and fun
for all